[Music]
another slark famous for speaking her
mind in a much more controlled insane
way is Sharon Osbourne the co-host of
the talk sounded off about Megan Markos
father and he reportedly got upset about
it so you know what Sharon did she
doubled down it's so obvious that you
know you have a bad drinking problem you
just look at a guy in a color I think
maybe you've got a little problem here
I hope it's drink and it's not dementia
or something else that particular missus
always definitely team Megan Sherrod
admits she doesn't know Thomas Markel
personally but she definitely has an
opinion Meghan's half sister Samantha
lashed out at Sharon saying that old hag
can shut her mouth my sources tell me
that
Thomas Markel isn't a big drinker the
reason that he's overweight and what he
prefers more than alcohol is junk food
et's royal expert Katie Nichols says the
royal strategy in dealing with Megan's
family is to not dignify anything they
say with a response I don't think there
are any concrete plans at the moment for
Megan to go out and see her father I
don't even believe that they have spoken
on the phone since the day after the
royal weddings another star speaking her
mind about the Markel family is Olivia
Munn she revealed this about the
director of her upcoming film the
predator
Shane black hmm used to date Samantha
Markel the really crazy sister
yes he dated her back in the day did he
really yes and I think you know she's
real like angry she's got a lot of
grades and stuff in the present her
family is working against her
[Music]